hello everyone and welcome back to simon
says where i will answer some of your
questions
let's jump right in okay can we be
both an introvert and an extrovert if so
how do we capitalize on our traits
i mean introversion and extroversion are
not absolutes we're all sort of venn
diagrams of them and
we can also change obviously i really
like susan kane's
definition of introversion extroversion
where it's not about how socially
awkward you are or not
it's about energy um an extrovert wakes
up in the morning with no coins
and every social interaction they have
they get a coin at the end of the day
they feel rich
an introvert wakes up in the morning
with five coins and every social
interaction they have they spend a coin
and at the end of the day they feel
depleted and so i know plenty of uh
socially awkward extroverts but i know
people who aren't socially awkward and
they're also introverts so it's not
about
whether you like people or like stuff
it's i think where you get your energy
so yes yes yes
we all have elements of both depending
on the circumstances
but we definitely have natural
inclinations also
okay what should infinite minded
companies be thinking about
going into the second year of pandemic
well um infinite-minded organizations
should be
uh thinking the same thing they went
into the first year pandemic which is
this is just a moment in time uh when we
have an infinite mindset we think of all
of this stuff
as like a continuum that it's not good
or bad or right or wrong it's just
part of the journey and it's about
managing the journey for the long term
there's a chinese story that i love to
tell it's told many ways but the way i
know it is a young man is born with a
remarkable ability for horse riding and
everyone in the village says you're so
lucky
and the monk says we'll see and then he
falls off his horse and
breaks his leg and everyone in the
village says you're so unlucky and the
man
the monk says we'll see and then war
breaks out
then all the young men are sent off to
battle but he can't go because of his
busted leg
and the monk says and everyone in the
village says you're so lucky and the
monk says
we'll see so it's the same here which is
yes for all of the difficulty and
hardship that we have suffered over the
first year of pandemic
we've learned a lot as well we've
learned a lot about how to run our
businesses differently but
we've also learned to step back make
space ask people how they are
there's been a lot more empathy over the
pandemic
so i think the second year now that
we're kind of a little
sort of sick of all the quarantine and a
little exhausted by all of it the
question is is what can we do with all
those new skill sets
to make our companies stronger and
better when we eventually come out of
this
how can we actually leverage that stuff
as opposed to just reacting to it
okay next question um what
uh can we be leaders if we don't have
a team absolutely being a leader
has nothing to do with about
being in charge anything like that but
it's about seeing those around us
rise it's about wanting to see around
though it's about wanting to see those
around us succeed
so if you're for example a solopreneur
you still
interact with people you might have a
client you can
lead your client you can help them see
them be successful
um you will have people who will work
with you people that you're going to
hire
you can work with them to see them be
successful the way you interact with
absolutely every human being you can
bring those leadership qualities
to bear you can always practice good
leadership whether you're on a team
or not you still interact with
people okay how do we inspire a loved
one
who is struggling ah that one's rough
just be there for them when somebody's
struggling sometimes all they need at
the beginning is just to know that
they're not alone
all they need is to know that someone
cares one of the best things you can do
is just check in on them ask them how
they're doing
the one of the worst things we can do
when somebody's struggling is we swoop
in and try and fix the problems
men are particularly bad at this
don't try and fix anything um just be
there for someone
and and and reinforce i'm here with you
you're not alone
you're not alone and let them speak um
let them talk
um that's really a big part of it um
when someone feels like someone's got
their back
um it'll inspire them i promise
um any tips for improving attention span
uh you're talking to someone who has
shiny object syndrome
um uh you know practice meditation i
know
it's sort of i think sort of i think
overused as
a solution to things these days but uh
but meditation the whole concept of
meditation
is learning to focus on one thing
learning to
label a thought and put it out of your
mind so that you can stay focused
and if you can practice a little
meditation every single day five minutes
even
um i think it'll help you stay focused
um i think the other thing we can do
is be aware of uh
some of the things that distract us for
example our phones i talk about it all
the time
put your phone in black and white mode
it makes it less addictive you'll
actually spend less time on the phone
practice putting your phone in airplane
mode when you're around other people
um give yourself deadlines when you're
going to stop using your phone in the
evening
don't charge it by your bed charge it in
a different room overnight little things
like that
will actually help increase our
attention span because we become less
distractible we become less addicted to
things that distract us
let's see what else we got here how can
we avoid micro
managing oh first of all
the fact that you want to stop avoiding
micromanaging you're already on the
right course
so micromanaging comes from many reasons
one we think we're better at doing
something than somebody else
another reason is fear that if we don't
get involved they're going to screw it
up
and so how we can get better avoiding
micromanaging is taking a deep breath
and having the courage
to allow someone to get things wrong and
to allow someone to get things
right it's one of the single biggest
things that i think
a leader has to learn which is learning
to let go
that we're now no longer responsible for
the work we're now responsible for the
people who responsible for the work
try to see yourself rather as a teacher
rather somebody who's there to take care
of someone to help them learn a skill
change in your mindset what your job is
it's not
to get the perfect product out anymore
that's their job your job is to help
them
and doing it for them they'll never
learn somebody let you try somebody let
you fail somebody let you try again once
before that's how you got good at it in
the first place
pay it forwards okay how can we make our
voice better heard on a team
um i this this comes up a lot
there are multiple ways sometimes we
have to evaluate is it the team or is it
us
um are we a good fit on the team are we
not being heard because
um we are doing the same thing over and
over and over again and then
just sort of like nobody listens to me
as opposed to learning to adjust our
language
um i've seen this happen in meetings
where somebody like
sort of varies of like i need to tell
you i need to tell you and people start
tuning them out
and then they start adjusting to be like
um so
here's an idea that might work um in
other words try different techniques
um also maybe try on smaller scale in
other words
talk to one person work through an idea
with them first talk to another person
on the team
work through an idea with them first and
then by the time you present to the
group you've already
workshopped the idea with multiple
people and they're already on your side
also don't be afraid to give away credit
that's another big one
um uh in other words if there's
something that somebody said that
even though it originally came from
you'd be like that's a great idea what
else could we do with that
or as julie said i want to pick up on
what julie's idea was in other words
share the credit and give away the
credit
sometimes it's a great way for people to
hear you because they don't think you're
trying to take all the credit
hopefully that helps okay how do we let
our bosses know that we're struggling
with our mental health without being
thought of as weak
um so here's the good news the good news
we're living in a world where
the concept of mental health is now uh
on everyone's mind we are talking about
it in terms of
uh healthcare workers we're talking
about in terms of frontline workers
we're talking about it in terms of
teenagers and kids who aren't at school
and aren't socializing so
the good news is is um i think it's it's
less stigmatized than it has been even
just a year ago
um and i i think it takes a little bit
of courage
to go to um a boss and say um
i i need your help because i'm
struggling and
and to say you know for whatever the
reason is let's use covert
uh you know the situation of covet is
really getting at me
and uh i don't know what to do and then
be quiet
um they may not be equipped with the
skill set to hear you
you have to acknowledge that they may
care but not know what to do they may
try and fix they may not be good
listeners
um but if you need to tell your boss
you're struggling
i think you need to take a deep breath
and tell your boss you're struggling
i would also tell other people as well
people who you're less afraid of talking
to that you work with
that will also really help but it's
great that you want to
that you want to do that and you want to
muster the courage just as an aside you
know one of the things we saw in cobit
struck for example
was a lot of uh leader a lot of people
in leadership positions where they were
effective leaders or ineffective leaders
prior to kovid
they they leaned back on their on their
humanity
and people picked up the phone and
called each other and said how are you
are you okay
so the good news is i think i think
you'll find more receptive audience now
than you used to
okay here's another one uh if we're
struggling to stay optimistic how do we
find the light at the end of the tunnel
one of the best ways to stay optimistic
is to help someone else
believe it or not one of the best ways
to solve our own problems
is to perform an act of service if you
have a friend or a colleague who's
struggling to
stay optimistic help them be there for
them
let them know that they're not alone let
them know that you're there with them
and that together you will get through
this um
and end up in a brighter place uh uh
than we are now get through this tunnel
and the amazing thing is the more you
reinforce those relationships the more
that others know that you're there for
them
the more they'll be there for you and
it'll help you feel that you're not
alone
so service helps um can families or
couples have a why
how do they find it yes absolutely just
like an individual can have a why
and a company can have a y um absolutely
a group can have a y
um and the way you find a y for uh
for a family or a couple is the same way
you would do it for an organization
it's something called an organizational
why i wrote it in the book find your why
um i wrote about how to find your
individual why but also
how to find an organizational why that's
the technique you would use because it's
an amalgamation it's the patterns
of all of the groups together of all the
people together of the or the couple
together that would form the y so yes i
love that you're even asking that
question yes yes yes you can
do it as a group how do we determine if
a goal
is unrealistic
is a goal unrealistic i mean isn't it
better to set an unrealistic goal
uh like is it better to set a goal of
100 and fail at 80
rather than set a goal of 30 and be
ecstatic when you hit 29
i think all goals should be unrealistic
uh and uh the trick is not the goal
being unrealistic the trick is being
okay with missing the unrealistic goal
knowing
that you're further down the path than
all the people with their realistic
goals
so yes set unrealistic goals they're
just more fun
[Music]